wait guys I've been waiting like a year
to get this water this is the most this
is why I wanted to come on this podcast
cuz every time I come in this room I see
these waters and I want them so bad you
know especially on this [ __ ]
always like oh yeah no those are uh her
guests George oppression stop good nasal
good nasally do you miss fat Gilbert you
know it's funny because I forget that he
was fat and when I look at pictures from
us when we first met maybe that's why I
don't hang out with you that much
anymore
anymore [ __ ] I mean killing you I mean
even the time that I've known you you've
changed believed gotten fancy they're
just something more like even like
before we even started this podcast I
was just like you said you were hungry
right yeah and I'm hungry too that's why
as well listen and then I felt like I'm
gonna throw this out there even though
he might say no but I said yeah but you
said yes was a miracle was maybe they'll
eat something afterwards right just to
see but like that shouldn't be a
question in my heart in my heart I
should be like oh he better [ __ ] eat
with me yeah yeah I mean it's a
privilege to eat with me no it's not
with you with you it's like it is a
privilege and I think it's a privilege
to but we have like very specific foods
that we eat because of our health and
you because you're fat no I think he's
now taking he's at another level or he
think season and I think yeah you're
just fancier man fancy I still drive
lifts your hair it's fancy any of them
fancy layered cheekbones are fancy yeah
you're getting fancier yeah we are using
skin care products that is true but you
introduced me to that I did that's not
yours so do you she said this is what
Bobbie uses she gave me a thing what did
I use
right Heydrich what is it the hyaluronic
acid no other retro no the brand
Oh Olay Henriksen at wash she's like
Renzo you do I use it Roley Hendrickson
no why did you tell me that I said I did
and you were like okay out they'll use
it oh yeah Renzo Renzo Renzo uses it
yeah Gardo Manor can use : puts it on
your face while you're asleep too when
men start doing stuff like that it not
only fancy it just it separates me
between me and you like when Sebastian
Maniscalco which he was showing me he
goes look at your nails yeah okay yeah
these are like working-class coalminer
hands you know I ain't no Foofa floof
what mine are you yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] ain't fancy [ __ ] I'm a coal
miner - now you're a mutant from your
girl I want to instead of doing this you
do this you know if they get the same
geez what is that it's his third gig
calcium dude it's so funny because you
hide that the [ __ ] mutant thing I
don't I'd it I'm not getting it off
until I book a series regular role
really yeah and then how much does it
cost to get that thing off free no I
mean I want it I want it I want to
remove it on my own it's very simple I'm
gonna chew on it is it a wart can I do
this it's a nozzle so it's a there's
actually a gap between the actual finger
and there's gilbert ass yeah see when
you were fat you'd let her to work yeah
oh yeah go ahead with a girl show the
boobs oh it's not a wart
Anna also very catchy Gilbert is not a
girl crazy anymore cuz he's in a
relationship so it is stabilized him I
will say I did utilize you for photos to
make myself look cool that's fine I know
I told I'm here for y'all your whatever
the [ __ ] you need to use me for don't
say that out loud
[Music]